the epigenetic
angle is fascinating that there will be
these epigenetic perturbations that lead
to
memories living from one generation to
the other
and then bringing those memories to the
surface and using
using that as signal to understand what
exactly the psychedelics bring
to the surface and not yeah yeah now the
other
portion of that though is culture i mean
culture is where we store all these
memories
and then the stories that we get passed
down
especially with a lot of shared you talk
about the holocaust or world war two
where it is um
it's deeply ingrained in the culture the
impact of those events
and sort of in aggregate the different
perspectives on that
particular event create a set of stories
that you can plug into
and then they kind of resonate with some
aspect of you that creates a memory
that's
connected to like when i think about
world war ii and the holocaust i think
about my own family
but in some sense it's also resonating
with stories of
many others so it's like somehow the two
echo each other
and i'm just providing my own little
flavor on top
the the meat of the stories are probably
those that are shared with others
it's plugging into the collective
unconscious that that's
um that's really fascinating really
plugging
into like precisely plugging into
particular memories
as a way to uh to to uh
deal with trauma and ptsd that kind of
thing
yeah i'll just have that the um most
important dream of my life
ever was of a holocaust survivor telling
me
that he was miraculously
saved from death
and he knew that he was saved for a
particular purpose but he never knew
what that purpose was so in the dream
i'm seeing him on his deathbed and
um and then he shows me whatever
happened to him during the holocaust
you know and then um we're back in the
room on his deathbed and he says well i
know what my
purpose was now and i'm like oh great
what was it he said let's
tell you to be a psychedelic therapist
and to study psychedelics and
bring back psychedelic research and
i thought to myself i've already decided
to do this you can lay this on me
i can say yes and then you can die in
peace and then he died in front of my
eyes
in the dream so i think that that kind
of
cultural transmission that i got from
when i was really young
you know then manifested in this dream
and that was this
story about how people can be
incredibly vicious and can be very
motivated by
irrational factors and so i i just feel
that
this this kind of multi-generational
transmission of this story of the
irrational
you know being a murderous factor um
and something i needed to respond to
was deeply ingrained and i i would say
my guess is you know more culturally
than this epigenetic
mechanism yes yeah but your sense is
that
whatever stimulated a certain
part of human nature in uh world war
ii especially not to germany but also in
stalinist soviet union still is within
us within all of us just like we were
saying uh you know
um we embody quite a lot of things
yeah and one of those is whatever the
the capacity of for evil
i seems to be one of those things
you